en réponse il y aura unet
Kim Vermette.
- Il fai après-mi après-mi aprÉe
Paquet Poisson fait du macramé
dans un parc de Québec.
Elle décide de retirer
son chandail. C'est alors
uvrir. Elle a dénoncé
cette situation sur Facebook.
Sa publication, partagée
des milliers de fois, a récolté
des centaines de réactions.CROIe
manifestation Libérez les seins
- Ça a été le catalyste pour
que ça explose sur plusieurs
issues.
- Après avoir lu l'histoire
d'Éloyze, Alice Lacroix a lancé
un appel à sortir manifester,
seins nu, pour celles qui
doivent changer pense-t-elle.
- On sait tous que l'égalité
des sexes est pas encore
arrivée. Je pense à ce qui
Centre Eaton qui s'est fait
mettre dehors pour allaiter,
avec les codes vestimentaires
dans les écoles qui sont
- Mais l'idée de voir une femme
seins nus, en public, continic,e
de susciter le malaise.
- On voit les seins comme
qu'il faut cacher. Mais dans
les années 60, il
exactement les mêmes, mêmes,
mêmes débats avec la mini-jupe.
LILI BOISVERT, directrice-
adjointe
- Ça semble anodin, mais c'est
que ça en dit beaucoup surcoup r
la puissance du tabou et
la volonté inscidila société der
le corps des femmes.
- L'autrice Lili Boisvert
a déjà mené l'expérience.
dans les rues seins nus.
L'article est devenu viral,
les réactions nombreuses.
- Si j'avais été un homme, ça
aurait éce que j'étais une femme
ça a tout changé pour moi
à ce moment-là, intimement et
publiquement dans ma carrière.
- Un signe du chem elle. Car
année après année, le débat esti
s'organise s'est même invitée
au parlement, à Québec.ministree
condition féminine
- Ça - Ça - Ça - Ça - Ça leur at
leur droit, puis... allez-y
j'ai aucun problème avec çaode
criminel canadien n'interdit
es d'être seins nus
en public. Seuls les actes
indécents sont interdits.rs, lex
se sont déjà penchés sur
la question en Ontario et en
Colombie-Britannique. Et ils ont
Vermettre,
Radio-Canada, Mon